زعيم الغالبيه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
تشاك تشمر الذي
قال اكتفى بهذه العباره ان ام امر طرا على
الرئيس زيلنسكي مما دفع الى الغاء هذه
الاحاطه التي كانت تحصل في جلسه مغلقه
جلسه سريه لم يعطي الكثير من التفاصيل
ولكن الخلافات الموجوده بين اعضاء
الكونجرس ولا سما بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين هي السبب الرئيسي ال اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن والحزب الديمقراطي يضغطون
من اجل تخصيص 106 مليارات دولار
ل
للانفاق اوكرانيا ستحصل بموجب هذه الخطه
التي اعادتها اداره الرئيس جو بايدن على
61 مليار دولار وهناك مليارات اخرى لشؤون
داخليه و ولدعم اسرائيل الجمهوريين يريدون
تنازلات من الرئيس جو بايدن فيما يتعلق
بامن الحدود الجنوبيه وتدفق المهاجرين من
اجل الموافقه على هذه
الخطه الديمقراطيون يعدون لتصويت الاربعاء
على مشروع القانون هذا هناك حاجه الى عشره
اصوات من الجمهوريين من اجل تمرير هذه
الخطه المفاوضات لا تزال المستمره وهناك
خشيه حقيقيه من ان الولايات المتحده قد قد
تتوقف بصوره تامه عن دعم اوكرانيا مع
نهايه هذه السنه اذا لم
يحصل اذا لم تحصل اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
على هذا التمويل الجديد من